foreign
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter Theory today we're going to be
discussing the magical School bobert
Hall if I asked you about bobotal
Academy of magic I better could guess
what you'd say it's one of the three
largest visiting schools in all of
Europe and it also happens to be one of
the snobbiest am I right after all who
could forget Fleur de la cause cruel
words during the Hogwarts Yule Ball even
though she was attending the event as a
guest she wasted no time comparing the
festivities to the ones her famous
French school held and Fleur wasn't kind
in her comparison from the decorations
to the presence of friendly ghosts Fleur
was hard-pressed to find anything she
liked but bobator was more than just a
school for the high and torti its
students are among the most accomplished
Wizards and witches in the entire
Wizarding World and when it came to
fighting against dark wizard and witches
Hogwarts alumni could find no better
allies than the graduates of bulbatore
especially when compared to durmstrang
the place where far darker Wizards and
witches seemed to graduate So today
we're going to take a step back and dive
into the depths of history as we take a
look at how bobotal came to be and why
it Rivals Hogwarts as one of the
greatest Wizarding schools in the world
early history it's hard to avoid
comparing bobaton to Hogwarts the two
seem to go hand in hand and even when we
look back at the very first day bovato
opened its doors we have to first
reference Hogwarts and that British
schools early history because bobaton's
established date is a bit of a mystery
we know that they were up and running by
the end of the 13th century that much is
sure they must have been since they were
one of the competitors in the Triumph
was a tournament which began around 12
19 A.D
but it'd be hard to say exactly how many
years before then they started Hogwarts
itself was founded around 990 so he
wouldn't be wrong to Guess that bombatol
also got their start by that point and
just like Hogwarts it only took a short
time for bombatol to become a
world-renowned school and the
destination for Europe's most affluent
Wizarding families unlike Hogwarts which
attracted students from the British
Isles bobotal recruited from all over
Continental Europe the location of its
Palace certainly helped add to its
appeal while Hogwarts was tucked away in
the cold Scottish Highlands the Palace
of bombatol was situated in the resort
town of Cairns in southern France right
across the sea from Corsica at least
that's what the earliest histories tell
us later different texts claim that the
palace was actually located in the
Pyrenees Mountains whatever the case may
have been the school grounds were
undoubtedly gorgeous they were covered
in Lush flower-filled Gardens and ornate
ancient statues even though Fleur could
have been a bit Kinder when bragging
about her school she certainly wasn't
wrong when it came to Beauty there were
few magical institutes that could
compare with bobatal
and even their mode of transportation
reflected that while most other Wizards
and witchers navigated the world aboard
their broomsticks and occasionally an
enchanted motorcycle the students at
bobato had a more elegant ride they
often used flying horses of course we
all saw that when Madame olymp Maxime
the headmistress of bomitor escorted her
students to the revived try was a
tournament in 1994. they rode carriages
drawn by abrax and horses and students
who are even rumored to ride them alone
even though it was against Wizarding
laws while Hogwarts allowed ghosts to
take up residence on its grounds The
Faculty at bombetor forbaded but there
were other magical creatures that called
the school home most famously bobato's
Great Hall was filled with wood nymphs
while the students ate their meals the
wood nymphs would serenade them with
Angelic songs which would be quite a
treat if you've only ever been used to
watching nearly headless
yank his head from his shoulders during
the holiday season the wood nymphs were
accompanied by Ice statues that sparkled
in the candlelight curriculum when it
comes to curriculum the Wizards and
witches of bobotal might have had an
advantage of their Hogwarts peers even
though both schools were comparable the
students at bomota started their testing
a full year after their fellow students
at Hogwarts that meant they were able to
focus on more Practical Magic instead of
focusing on Note memorization as the
boys and girls at Hogwarts School were
forced to do and just like Hogwarts
bobato didn't teach their students about
the dark arts while Europe's other great
magical School The durmstrang Institute
instructed their pupils in the basic
tenets of dark magic bobitor actively
avoided it but you don't really need to
pour over the class schedules of bobotal
to judge their curriculum if you take
one look at the French Academy's
performance in the tri-wizard tournament
then you can see just how skilled their
faculty and students were they had over
60 victories in the games and only
trailed behind Hogwarts by one
Championship famous graduates now if
you're not sure why you've never heard
of bobert Hall's famous graduates the
fact is you have some of the greatest
Sorcerers and Alchemists in the history
of the Wizarding World graduated from
bobotal rest assured there were far more
interesting alumni than Fleur De La
Calle although she was no slouch herself
for starters boboton was a school where
Nikola Flamel studied in his youth if
you can't quite remember who Flamel was
don't worry you might know him by his
most famous creation the Philosopher's
Stone Flamel learned the secrets of
alchemy and used his Newfound knowledge
to create a stone capable of providing
an unnaturally long life that's how the
wizard managed to live for over six
centuries it could also turn metal into
gold it wasn't until the second Rise of
old Voldemort that Flamel wisely decided
to destroy his Stone and accept his own
death after all Flamel agreed with Albus
Dumbledore if the Philosopher's Stone
ever fell into Voldemort's hands the
world itself might have been destroyed
another famous wizard Vincent Duke
Detroit
in the 18th century during the
tumultuous French Revolution the wizard
cunningly used his magic a concealment
charm in particular to avoid a mob
execution and was one of a handful of
lucky ones to do that but among
bobaton's long list of graduates you
might recognize the oversized limp
Maxime she was the headmistress of the
academy during the Triumph was a
tournament of 1994. just like everyone
else she attended the games and
witnessed the first signs of Lord
Voldemort's return unlike Igor kakarov
the Headmaster of the durmstrang
institute's maxim wasn't fond of the
dark arts she quickly realized that
Albus Dumbledore would need her help to
fight against Voldemort and joined his
side when the Hogwarts Headmaster tried
to enlist Giants to his cause since
Maxim herself was rumored to be half
giant Dumbledore supposed that Maxim's
charms combined with Hagrid's Heritage
might be enough to sway the Giants the
small differences if we dive into the
nitty-gritty we can find a few more fun
differences between bobator and Hogwarts
as you might have expected this French
school's dress code was Far different
and even though the film suggested that
bobato only accepted female students
they allowed men to enroll as well when
running around their own Palace grounds
the students at bobator were expected to
wear their school's colors they often
wore short capes around their shoulders
during formal occasions but while
attending Class A simple skirt and
jacket for girls was acceptable and
presumably trousers and a jacket for
boys would have been as well and bobato
might have actually benefited from
having a long-lived Alchemist as one of
their graduates according to rumors the
school received a large annual gift from
the Flamel family wealth which he
amassed through the centuries in his
honor the school constructed a giant
water fountain in the center of its
largest Garden but it wasn't simply a
lovely water display there were tales
that this Fountain held mystical
properties that only an alchemist could
concoct Legacy when we look back at
bobato's long history and wonder what
type of Legacy they've etched out for
themselves it's hard to really pin it
down what we know of the school comes in
bits and pieces from sources in the
British Wizarding World those sources
famously favored Hogwarts and during the
life of Harry Potter most news coverage
centered around the second Rise of Lord
Voldemort who was a uniquely British
threat since the dark lord had not yet
launched an attack against Continental
Europe there was no reason for the
Wizards and witches of bombota to do
more than an offer Aid which they did
but that wasn't the type of thing that
made it into newspapers at least not
when Harry Potter was actively engaging
Death Eaters in combat but that's not
exactly their fault bobato is a great
school and one of the best in Europe it
never produced Heroes like Hogwarts but
it never produced dark Lords either in
the end it was a school and by the looks
of it a pretty good one and that's it
for this video do you have anything to
add about bobotal leave a comment down
below as always if you enjoyed the
content please like the video and
subscribe to the channel until next time
remember happiness can be found even in
the darkest of times if one only
remembers to turn on the light
foreign